this is ali habi ali in happier times
some years before his arrest at the
scene of the murder of mp sir david amos
the british man aged 25 is of somali
background
at a somali cafe in london there was
shock and sadness as more details of the
suspect emerged
i was taken aback by it because i felt
like i'm somali known
sounds
like surreal somali man especially at
that age 25 years old the somali
community they're very sad
the suspect grew up in a modest home
with his younger brother and two sisters
one neighbor remembered him playing
football in this street close to croydon
town centre
a ten minute walk away is the church of
england primary school where ali and his
siblings were among the first muslim
families to attend
at ali's secondary school staff have
been working with police
the chief executive said everyone there
was devastated by the arrest of a former
pupil
two of ali's former teachers have
described him as a dedicated
hard-working pupil right up to his
success at a levels
one teacher remembered him as a polite
well-behaved boy always ready to engage
with his classmates at primary school he
took part in regular christian worship
this is the house where ali had been
staying before the mp stabbing in essex
on friday
police have now completed their searches
here and elsewhere
detectives have another four days in
which to question their suspect
they could hold him for a week beyond
that if they need to and if they can
justify it to a judge
martin brunt sky news in south london